even as mass coveted vaccination sites
open up
all around the country many older people
are saying they run into trouble trying
to sign up
online now people known as vaccine
hunters are stepping up to help
amid a patchwork of state rules these
volunteers are spending hours online to
land appointments
for total strangers nancy chen
introduces us to one new york family
that's already helped more than 750
older neighbors
get their shots i
received a phone call from many
acquaintances and friends did you call
the number did you get an appointment
i said i'm just hearing frustration
among frustration for seniors like 81
year old jeannie mcdowell
they didn't have an iphone they don't
have a computer what were they supposed
to do
securing an appointment seems impossible
until they reach out to deidre de castro
okay no problem
i can help you with that went from a
cell phone to
multiple laptops turned into a command
center yes
in our kitchen dicastro and her family
have booked vaccine appointments by the
hundreds and their central new york
community
i just need your name as it appears on
your license
all for total strangers and for free
we do it between lunch dinner
pretty much all the time
[Music]
the castro is often up until three in
the morning rapidly refreshing websites
for any availabilities
now my husband calls it whack-a-mole you
have to be quick because
there's ten thousand other people doing
probably the same thing
her husband marco delivering the printed
confirmation tickets
she first realized the difficulties in
getting an appointment while signing up
her mother-in-law
word got out fast after dicastro started
helping neighbors
i heard some seniors even say they would
get on the computer
they might lose the sight they
put in rome new york and ended up in
rochester
and my other dear friend got on the
phone
and the lady said call back at 4. she
called back at four and the tape said
the office is closed
dicastro got an appointment in just days
for mcdowell and her husband
only two of the 25 the de castro's book
on average each day
for anyone who asks including the petrie
family
vicki was very stressed by the time she
got everything in
the appointment was gone vicki and dave
petry reached out for their daughter
jessica who has down syndrome
after struggling on their own she helped
us
she helped our neighbors she helped my
brother and his wife
get an appointment she just i don't know
how she does it the castro's reach has
now spanned four counties
people express her gratitude with cards
and even home-cooked dinners but
decastro says
she's just doing anything possible to
protect her community
i treat everyone as if they're my parent
yesterday wouldn't have been soon enough
for me if it were my parents
when will you stop when they stop
calling
i would love for everybody to feel safe
again
it's not soon enough for cbs this
morning
nancy chen rome new york wow
miss de castro castro family yes you're
right all of them all of them
it's interesting if you're technically
challenged and you're older how
difficult this is you need somebody to
help you
so many people in that situation they're
real here